love this guy uh we interviewed him for
one of our podcast specials back in the
day
before this show was born right i did
chris um
at the nfl offices at the nfl offices
yes
back in the day uh loved his i just love
this guy
and he's on the moody's uh season two
premieres with two back-to-back episodes
on thursday night at nine eastern on fox
he is dennis leary how are you dennis
hello rich eisen
where are you right now dennis where
have i found i am back
uh in new york actually i was up in
canada
shooting the moody's uh until about a
week ago okay
talk about cutting it close yeah so i'm
i'm finally back in new york
back in new york city um so
so uh how how do you handle brady
winning for somebody
um else that's strange
um times for for boston sports fans
right i mean
the red sox let's not even get into that
yes we can leave them aside sure uh yeah
i mean
we're back to we're almost to where we
were before
before the late 90s started
right so you know
uh you know i'm a a huge foster fan and
i
and i you know i uh coach belichick i
mean
you did that uh that amazing special
with him which is one of the greatest
things i've ever seen that the greatest
players of all time
and that was fantastic it was amazing
thank you oh my god
just that was like such i couldn't wait
for each new episode to come on when
that thing was on
well he was amazing dennis i mean and
again i think i know you reached out to
me
when that aired uh on nfl network the
the nfl 100
uh all-time team um being around
belichick made me think there's no way
anybody could ever beat him certainly if
it comes down to just him matching wits
with somebody else
because he yeah the the stories that he
would share
that he would pass along to the team to
make sure that they were situationally
prepared like well one time when
jerry rice uh you know uh beat us
this way or you know one time you know
when uh march of brother told me about x
y and z
and he passes that along to his players
like who else can do that
i mean no i mean hey listen and it
well anyway i mean i don't have to tell
you how great the show was and the fans
out there know but yeah
it really puts on display how deep it is
and if i got the genius label just how
deep his knowledge about football
past present and and future has always
been right
so you know it's an astonishing level of
of
information he has in his head so you
know
i mean i have to go along with coach
belichick when tom brady leaves i
i we don't have a lot of pieces we need
to spend some money we need to have
better drafts and everything you know so
it was the weirdest football season
because we sucked
the patriots sucked and and it was clear
to me from the beginning like we're just
going to suck this is
you know this is going to be really
interesting because we're going to suck
i can only hope secretly that things
don't go well in tampa bay because
you're thinking
if they suck in tampa bay maybe tom
comes back
you're holding out hope for that dennis
this is this is how how how
uh you know blatant of a uh a brady
belichick reunion i wanted i was like
things will [ __ ] tampa bay tom says
uh maybe i should retire
belichick you know entices them back to
the patriots
i i have to say also as a football fan
just as a patriots fan you know watching
brady like you said
you guys are just saying it's crazy
seven out of ten
come on yeah well look astonishing i
know it really is
uh unlike anything else the numbers are
stupid they're ridiculous
they're stupid and you have mahomes you
know you have a team that the defending
champions
with you know one of the uh potentially
greatest quarterbacks
from his generation right and he just
goes in there and goes like yeah and the
gronk and the other guy yeah okay we got
it
yeah oh my god i know
i don't mean i mean i didn't mean i
guess i meant to go there just to start
it but
you know well listen there's no way not
to go there for a good we're going to
talk about that are we going to talk
about mookie bets goes to l.a
let's turn around fighting me in the ass
but i think
i was thinking about this because i i
knew you'd bring it up i was like you
know what
it's sort of payback time a little bit
for boston fans i mean
the bruins are in contention they're
having some problems right now the
celtics are okay
but you know we had a lot of
championships
so maybe it's time we have to a little
downtime for us but i have a lot of
faith in coach belichick the signings
you know i i think he's he's he he knew
he had to rebuild so he's rebuilding uh
you know
i have some faith now as you know uh
dennis leary here on the rich eisen show
as you know
um you have to make smart decisions in
the draft um
being the coach of draft day dennis
you've seen that firsthand
you know how you know listen uh you know
i don't know if you had
i don't know if you had the same power
uh as belichick does
in draft day you know i did uh you know
not a lot of people
know this but uh i used uh
coaches the coach the character was kind
of loosely based on
uh john gruden okay but they kind of
threw that away
uh but i i approached you know i asked
uh
coach belichick if he would give me if
you read the script and give me some
notes his research which he did
come on um really yeah which is yeah
which was really nice of him but it's
hilarious because there were several
instances in the movie
know there's the thing where we plant uh
you know some money in a playbook to see
if a player
uh actually reads the playbook you know
uh
because if he did he'd find a 20 bill
you know he was like yeah well that was
our thing we did that with the giant
like everything that was a reference
point of comedy
or football knowledge in there he knew
about so he picked them out he's like
yeah that's from blah blah that's from
bing bang boom
you know so but yeah i actually got
coach belichick to give me some pointers
on
what i need to know and not know what
was real or not real
in terms of my character get out of here
i did not know that so did he get yeah
because you know again he picks the
groceries there too did he give costner
that whole thing about having uh the the
note in his pocket
about the players
[Laughter]
okay but he did he was like he's like
listen you know you should do
this and you should you know uh i you
know i actually said
you know it would be on the nose i had
said like you know i'm going to try to
talk these guys into letting me dress
like you
he was like yeah you can do that if you
want but to ivan reitman's credit the
director he was like now that's we don't
want to be belichick so that's not
you know what i mean so but um yeah it
was interesting because
you know he he uh he's such a
fascinating guy i think i might have
told you this story before but
years ago when we were doing rescue me
when i first got to know him which was
through a couple of mutual friends you
know
um he he was a fan of the show and he
said hey you know
we were at some charity fundraiser or
something and he said hey
you know i'm coming to new york you know
next month if you guys are shooting i'm
like yeah we are shooting so i'd love to
buy the set to see what it's like so i
was like of course the guys on the set
you know they're all sports fans right
you guys in that cast so i'm like
okay so i tell everybody hey coach
belichick might be coming you know and
they're all like
what so phil esposito played a
small recurring role as a as a captain
uh fire captain on the show so i set it
up like
coach belichick will be there the same
day you know and he'll come in
and he'll do like you know he'll get a
little cameo if he wanted to be on
camera which was like oh that would be
fantastic because he wanted to meet phil
right sure espo but i have to tell you
when he came on that set
you know he he didn't have to be there
for like six o'clock at night because we
were shooting you know
bulk of the day without him he said can
i come first thing in the morning i'm
like yeah he came
he has a notebook and you know we're
busy you know getting set up by the
monitor so we can watch what we're
shooting
and he's he keeps asking questions he's
like so now what are those
those guys over there what do they do
i'm like oh those are the grips so when
we need to
have some stuff fixed lighting-wise they
come in their boss is that guy
and he's like oh and he starts writing
down notes and for the rest of the
afternoon he's writing notes and
watching people
interact and then asking questions like
so now what about this thing
when the actors you know are ready to go
and uh what about the prize
i'm like this is really interesting and
at lunch time he goes hey this is just
like a team
i mean it's and i'm like oh yeah yeah
it's totally like a team music
yeah i'm very interested in the
psychology the way i see everybody and
i'm like holy
this is unbelievable we can't believe it
like we're
that's amazing yeah so literally the
most curious guy how those lights run up
there
you know how those run because this was
on the stage you know in the studio
stage
he just was fascinated by everything but
he was also he didn't know about it so
he wanted to find out what it was like
and he's right because of course
filmmaking is like a team you have like
150 200 people there
the actors are the thing everybody sees
but you know there's people handing us
the props
people like all that and he was very
interested in how that ran
and how how you kept the spirits up
because you could see that we were all
sort of you know
making each other laugh and with the
same thing with the crew so it was
really fascinating for him but i was
fascinated that he would
be that interested in it you know what i
mean well i mean he's curious because
you never know what he can pick up about
anything
to do with the team does that make you
the brady of this scenario
dennis you know what rich i'm glad you
pointed that out
[Laughter]
although unlike brady when it came to
the ending that was 0 for 10.
i think i was i was over five at the end
even over five at the golden globes
there you go
there you go if you were only on the
dl12 system dennis
who knows you could have gone seven for
ten the l12 system you know what that is
that's uh that's seven cups of coffee
and 25 cigarettes
that's what that is jameson
[Laughter]
no oh my god that's so that's so funny
the dl12 the l12
with a little bit of electrolytes is
jameson you know something like a
cigarette
yeah cigarette six beers that's the dl12
dennis leary here on the rich eisenhower
yeah
before i get to the moodies um what was
you i miss being in this
live in the studio i mean well we miss
you too except for the fact that you
you you fired a a golf ball at me one
time
dennis you're like literally seven
ironed it in my direction
rich you know there's only two shows in
the history of all the talk shows i've
ever done that's from
you know letterman all the way up to
present day only two
shows have been allowed to take over the
desk
and turn the host into the uh sidekick
okay the
the daily show with john stewart and the
rich eisen show is the only time
i will take that and run with i will
take no one can never take that away
from me to use the football championship
phrase
we always have that rich
i don't remember it when my life flashed
before my eyes when i saw that uh
callaway go right past my head that was
great you know i
i have a picture of uh some one of your
guys or somebody took a picture of me
firing that golf ball and then they took
a picture of me at the desk when i took
over
i haven't i have them in my phone
someplace fantastic well
we'll post them too at rich eisenhower
uh dennis leary here on the program
before i get to the moodies with you
uh what was it like to be on the set of
the sandlot
how old were you and that was the
beginning of your career
and man i've got so many questions did
you have any idea
what that could possibly be in terms of
all-time sports movies
no so i my career had just taken off you
know uh
in terms of getting famous and i had
done uh
you know i had a couple movies in the
camp big movies and
somebody called you know but they were
like uh one was demolition man i think
was
either had yeah demolished a man had
just started
in judgment night right yeah um
they were they were the they were sort
of they hadn't come out yet right
and they were big budget movies you know
and yeah action movies
so somebody called me i can't remember
who and said hey there's this little
baseball movie
right blah blah blah and i go oh that's
interesting so i got the script and i
was like wow this is just like this is
literally just about a bunch of kids
playing baseball
and the part you know was uh was
sort of i think it was like two weeks i
had to shoot you know what they were
shooting for like six i was only
shooting for two weeks
so i looked at and i said you know i'm
gonna do this because this is
like i like the story you know i'm one
of those guys like you know i cry to
feel the dreams you know what i mean i'm
like
a baseball guy a sports guy father's son
so that's why i took it and then you
know then i was like what did i just do
they always tell you don't work with
dogs and kids those are the two things
you don't want to work with
in show business right and i'm working
with a giant dog and all kids
right so i got there and i'll be honest
with you you never know what the movie's
gonna be bigger than that but those kids
the director was he had they had been
working already for a couple of weeks
and he had those kids
in such uh you know their energy was all
sort of uh focused at the right
points when the cameras were rolling and
i'm looking at these kids and i'm going
these kids are great
you know they're really fantastic so
the funny part was in between uh
takes they were they were you know they
were all little kids but some of them
were
actually older already you know mentally
as well as physically
so that kid benny the jet the kid who
played my
son his sister was there and she was
slightly older she was like
14. and benny is a jet um
every time we took a break in like a
lighting break or a setup so it's like
15 20 minutes
and it was time to start shooting again
they'd go ah
somebody go get benny the jet and he off
be off flirting with
my son's uh sister so i was like well
this kid
this kid's the one who's on the ball but
anyway
it was you know you could tell the kids
were good you know so you never know if
a movie's gonna have staying power but
those kids
were they really had a they were funny
you know they were uh
energetic on camera they were great um
and i shot for two weeks and and crossed
my fingers and now you know literally
how many years later it's still
it's crazy yeah i mean you could do the
math it's 27 years later
it's so and and um and so many people
name it as one of their top fav
as one of their favorite sports movies
of all time were any of your shoot days
on the same day as james earl jones or
or did you
yes but you know that was uh i didn't
have any scenes with him which is
right now now you know he's james earl
jones that's right right
and i'm just starting out he has no idea
why but he was the kindest
nicest sweetest guy right just
and it did it's an extraordinary actor
so i i watched him work a little bit but
also
the way he treated everybody was just
amazing and then years go by
and i'm working with costner and i i
brought him up to casa and costa was
like
is he not the greatest sweetest guy
i mean and that voice as soon as he
starts talking to you in real life
you're just like oh my god you're
talking to god you know what i mean it's
like when i think of the voice of god i
think it's james earl
of course you know i know and he's been
in the sandlot and field of dreams and
that would you brought talking about
costner and draft day i mean you've been
in some uh
you know and obviously he's been in two
of the greatest sports movies of all
time and you've been in some
i mean that's great stuff man that
that's that's what listen
i cannot i think i've told you that
before i did that movie
you know i like football and i like ivan
reitman you know
and it was a good script but i did it
purely because i wanted to do a
cost or sports movie right the next best
thing would be a western
so i said yes right immediately
and costner was just you want to talk
about number one a great guy number two
just like you know you you when you're
working with him on camera man it's just
so he's so
good at what he does you know and and
honestly when you say sports movie with
costner you think he's he's
he's done doing it and then when he did
done doing those genres and then he does
draft day it was just like
seeing somebody you know an old friend
back
in the saddle you know what i mean and
his speech at the end of draft day is as
good as
any sports movie speech that he's ever
done let me tell you something else
about him like you know yellowstone is
getting
yes all the press for him right now
because it's a big hit television show
and that's in his wheelhouse you know uh
as a sort of modern day western right
but there was a movie came out this year
it didn't get nominated for an oscar but
it should have
called let him go did you see that i did
not no
so look look it up it's a little movie
called let him go with him and diane
lane
and it's a it's a western set in like
the
late 60s early 70s about him and
his his wife diane lane trying to get
their grandson back
and he again within the kevin costner
realm of what he does
he is so unbelievably good in that movie
it's just you know as an actor sometimes
i look at him i go like
this is why the guy's a movie star yeah
what i mean yeah he's so
good and you know how many westerns have
you seen him in and i'm watching him in
this movie i'm going like he's doing
stuff i've never seen him do before
it's amazing he's the best dennis leary
here on the rich eisen show let's talk
about the moody's
um you just fresh back from shooting it
uh what can we expect out of season two
what are you excited about
about this season two so there's the
thing i tell everybody is
you know yeah okay me and elizabeth
perkins and she is
astonishingly a great actress right you
know emmy winner
as opposed to me you know so people
might
you know hear my name and her name and
that's what they
you know they draws their attention but
i'm telling you that the three kids
francoise know who plays one of our sons
jay barachel
i don't know if you've ever interviewed
him yes uh
you know just and he's already got an
established
comedy uh you know street cred but
chelsea frye who plays my daughter she
is just unbelievably kick-ass in this
show she's
hilarious so those are i would say
listen if you're coming from me and
elizabeth you're going to find yourself
laughing at those three because they're
they're just genius but
um there's some there's a couple uh
hockey episodes
it wasn't my idea the writers created
this
so there's some good hockey stuff some
good sports stuff in there but
most of the time listen we're just it's
it's set up
uh this year that there's a family
wedding which you find out about
literally in the first 15 seconds that
has
obviously already gone wrong and then we
flashback
uh it's an easter wedding and then we
flashback uh to
how it went wrong that's basically the
entire eight episodes and the
back-to-back episodes start uh on
thursday night not eastern
on fox and elizabeth perkins you
mentioned she won uh some some awards
she's on the ep 12 system
dennis that's right that's what you got
to do on the ep 12 system
you got to go that's what you want let's
check it out that's what i'm saying
dennis that's called a call back
uh in in your industry
yes it is my friend joe actual retail
price
that's one of the best he is one of the
best uh
i had forgotten about that one yes joe
actually and
two uh jim two silhouettes on duchess is
my favorite
i think and also you but burke be home
by
11. that's exactly right i remember i
remember when i think when he first said
that one because i think i was watching
and i was just like
this guy's he's insane
you know yep that's berman hey dennis
he's the only one to come up with those
because you think you can come up with
them but you can't really you can't
you try he's he he's one of those guys
who who's
just like you said like costner he's
he's he's one of the all-time greats in
in
in on you know the television sports
profession in broadcasting professions
who is one of the nicest people but
again the number right what
one of the nicest guys no question
berman but the number of people that
come up to him say i got one for you you
know i
okay what do you got why are you even
trying
you know it's like going up to ted
williams and saying like listen i think
i have the solution
don't don't don't do that to boomer just
let him give you one
that's okay i know mike if you hear your
name and maybe he comes up with one for
you
exactly dennis thanks for the call let's
do this more often i
really enjoy seeing you when we're out
of this whether i have something to push
or not if i'm in l.a i'm coming to the
studio and the desk is yours sir
the desk will be yours i can't wait
thanks for the call dennis you take care
hi guys bye
he is the man dennis leary at dennis
leary on
twitter and instagram hey you watched
all the way to the end thanks for that
watch more right here